für die kanzlerin geht es um ihren job
eigentlich würde sie gerne bis 2021 im
amt bleiben aber hält es ihre partei mit
ihr bis dahin noch auswahl neuer
parteichef
wenn nicht dann raus aus der gruppe
unreinen neuwahlen ein möglicherweise
riskantes manöver die konstante merkel
die kanzlerin und die coco jetzt in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer bei
uns meine gäste im studio kerstin
münstermann ist bei uns chefreporterin
politik in der zentralredaktion der
funke mediengruppe und dahinter verbirgt
sich unter anderen die westdeutsche
allgemeine aus essen die hamburg das
hamburger abendblatt und die berliner
morgenpost das einfacher vorzustellen
ist christoph schwennicke denn der ist
chefredakteur eines politikmagazins
namens cicero heiko kretschmer ist
politik und kommunikationsberater hat
unter anderem spd wahlkämpfe begleitet
oder organisiert und in ihrem früheren
leben waren sie auch mal
stellvertretender juso-vorsitzender
robert veerkamp ist bei uns direktor des
programms zukunft der demokratie der
bertelsmann stiftung und mitautor einer
studie über die zwischenbilanz der groko
münstermann wie entschlossen sie die
kanzlerin eigentlich ihr amt verteidigen
gegen unkräuter angriffe aus der eigenen
partei oder der eigenen fraktion im
bundestag
ich glaube sie wird das bis aufs letzte
verteidigen egal ob es ein neuer
parteichef wird der armin laschet jens
spahn oder friedrich merz heißen sollte
ich glaube an merkel führt kein weg
vorbei
und jetzt mal muss die spd eigentlich
mit der kanzlerin bitten denn baldige
neuwahlen könnten ja zu einem desaster
für die sozialdemokraten führen dann
aber vom münstermann also ich glaube die
cdu hat auch gar kein interesse daran
momentan die kanzlerin zu stürzen die
kannst du dann hat ja gerade die
gemengelage sortiert insofern guckt die
spd er gerade entspannt auf den
bevorstehenden führungsstreit die
entscheidung über parteivorsitz
kanzlerkandidatur jetzt dran ist so
schönig korrigieren sind wenn das eine
bösartige unterstellung ist aber ich
glaube es haben den letzten jahren ihre
gesamte publizistische feuerkraft darauf
verwendet der kanzlerin nahezulegen
das ist jetzt langsam reicht aber wenn
sie jetzt ihren hut nimmt
wird wirklich alles besser nein
das erwarte ich da für mich ich teile
übrigens die ansicht von frau
münstermann dass sie alles tun wird es
nicht zu tun
diese beharrungskräfte imponiert mir
dann auch wieder das würde ich auch ganz
ehrlich sagen und auch die fähigkeit
leute die
gefährlich werden können so rechtzeitig
aus dem weg zu räumen oder mit guten
anderen posten zu versorgen dass sie
dann eben nicht mehr gefährlich wird nur
es hat frau kramp karrenbauer bei ihrer
erkenntnis dass sie vielleicht nur eine
sehr kleine chance hatte um die nicht
genutzt hat als cdu-vorsitzende oder
verspielt hat als cdu-vorsitzende einen
sehr wichtigen satz gesagt die
erkenntnis sei amt also kanzleramt und
parteivorsitz gehören in einer hand
jetzt gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
entweder frau merkel wird wieder
parteivorsitzende oder die person paar
namen sind schon genannt worden
dann werden auch nicht viel mehr dazu
kommen nach der sendung die person die
sich da an schickt es zu werden
parteivorsitzender sagt unter einer
bedingung
das muss einhergehen mit dem kanzleramt
und gegen diese argumentation ist dann
so leicht auch kein wirkliches kraut
gewachsen
wir werden uns dieser schwierigen frage
ganz bestimmt im laufe der sendung mehr
als nähern
daher kam ich habe gerade erwähnt sie
haben ja in einer studie mitgearbeitet
über die zwischenbilanz der groko wie
viel eigentlich ziemlich gut aus sie hat
ja geradezu in rekordzeit viele gesetze
die sie angekündigt hat den
koalitionsvertrag auch tatsächlich
angegangen oder sogar schon
verabschiedet fatalerweise denken die
bürger genau umgekehrt sie hätten gar
nichts gemacht oder wenig zu wege
gebracht die groko ist also viel besser
als ihr ruf aber zu diesen schlechten
ruf haben ja union und spd wesentlich
selbst mit beigetragen
das heißt also wenn es die eines tages
nicht mehr gebe die coco die würde man
kaum vermissen
na ja da bin ich mir nicht so ganz
sicher ob wir die nicht doch noch mal
vermissen würden weil man eben schon
sagen muss wir haben eine sehr
handlungsfähige regierung wäre auch eine
fleißig regierung wir haben eine
regierung von der man sagen kann und
auch sagen muss dass sie das was sie tut
was sie versprochen hat also die große
koalition hat in den ersten 18 monaten
ihre regierungszeit von den 296
koalitions versprechen sozusagen zwei
drittel entweder vollständig oder
zumindest substanziell umgesetzt das ist
eine wirklich gute regierungsbilanz ich
meine wir haben in dieser studie so eine
art koalitions tüv veranstaltet und der
tüv der beurteilt ja auch nicht wie
schön das auto ist und ob es in die
richtige richtung fährt sondern
beurteilt so zu sagen ob es
pferd und da muss man halt
zwischenbilanz ganz klar sagen wir haben
eine extrem handlungsfähige und fleißige
regierung also endlich da das etwas
anders beurteilen darf also erstens fand
ich ist ganz traurig das hat sich ein
bisschen wie so ein zwischenzeugnis
angehört wo man gesagt hat sich immer
redlich bemüht und wenn ich jetzt in dem
schul bild bleibe dann ist ihrer meinung
nach so zu sagen dass die leistung
dieses schülers oder in dem fall dieser
koalition die misst man an dem was ich
was er selber vorgenommen hat nein daran
messe ich keine koalition nicht messe
die auch nicht an der menge der
gesetzesentwürfe die sie dann auf den
weg bringen sondern ich messe sie an den
notwendigkeiten die da sind und da würde
ich sagen ist diese regierung gehörte
jetzt nicht zu den temperamentvoll ssten
in europa da sind handlungsfähig
handlungsfähigen frage gestellt aber
dies nur zu sagen da sind ganz viele
gesetze auf den weg gebracht worden
ich finde dass die so die die
veränderung der der mentalität in diesem
land das land auf mehr modernität
einzustellen digitalisierung und solche
fragen da ist überhaupt nichts passiert
und da sehe ich um uns rum tatsächlich
länder er mit jüngeren regierungschefs
wo ich da mehr besitzt bewegungen
beobachtet
also ich stimme ihnen dazu dass so eine
art der bilanz natürlich nicht das
politische urteile über die regierung
ersetzt
ich bin aber schon der meinung dass es
auch ein eigener wert von politik ist
wenn sie das was sie versprochen hat
auch tatsächlich umgesetzt weil das wird
er oft in der bevölkerung zum vorwurf
gemacht
die machen ja sowieso was sie wollen die
halten sich nicht an das was sie
versprochen haben oder was sie in so
einem koalitionsvertrag festgelegt haben
und deshalb finde ich schon dass darin
auch wirklich ein gewisser eigenwert
league treffen die selbstbeschäftigung
der regierung wie wir es jetzt bei der
union erleben wie wir es vorher war der
spd erlebt haben das hauptproblem
diese studie war ja im prinzip eine
zwischenbilanz um den blick zurück also
dokumentiert was gemacht worden ist das
ja noch nichts gesagt wie es jetzt in
bis zum einem wie auch immer gearteten
ende der legislaturperiode rausgeht
die groko wird ja von zwei parteien
angeführt die nicht nur sich mit
selbstbeschäftigung abgibt sondern deren
markenzeichen auch die
selbstbeschädigung ist ja aber ich rede
jetzt von der cdu und spd die csu ist da
im moment ja relativ fein raus aber wenn
das das markenzeichen des
selbstbeschädigung wie kann da
eigentlich ein regierungschef sicher
geführt werden unter diesen hypotheken
unter dem gerade spd und cdu so leiten
am ende sind es natürlich zwar
einbeinige die sich gegenseitig stützen
und die die tatsache dass es und ich
deswegen würde schon von drei parteien
werden in jeder phase dieser regierung
hat es eine partei gegeben
die sozusagen hochgradig angst haben
musste davor vor den wähler zu treten
und da gab es ja auch eine zeit wo die
csu in bayern sehr schlecht aussah jetzt
ist sie eigentlich der starke starke
schrittmacher das hat man ja auch dieser
tage gemerkt durch die auftritte von
söder der als erster orientierung nach
erfurt eigentlich aus gegeben hat dann
hat lange die spd gekannt und jetzt ist
der kelch weitergereicht und eine cdu
die kernfragen dieser republik nicht für
sich geklärt hat oder sie zumindest
nicht durchsetzen kann
und insofern eigentlich momentan auch
kein interesse daran haben kann
vor den wähler zu drücken jetzt haben
wir schon gelangt der großen koalition
fehlen mindestens zwei beine und
besonders temperamentvoll ist sie auch
nicht
was muss ich schon aber was muss ich
noch machen wir reden ja auch noch wie
weit sie oder wie lange sie noch am
leben bleibt das auch noch bestandteil
der sendung aber was muss jetzt
eigentlich machten und tritt zu fassen
und vielleicht auch ein bisschen davon
nicht abzulenken sondern wegzukommen
dass man sagt zwei dieser drei parteien
sind in einer richtigen krise
na ja es wäre schon mal genug die spd
hat das jetzt eigentlich versucht indem
sie die lage etwas beruhigt hat etwas
rausgenommen hat und gesagt hat wir
schweigen jetzt mal wir machen die kroko
erstmal weiter nun hat frau kam kaum
bauer die nerven verloren deswegen wird
die nächste zeit geprägt sein egal was
passiert von dem machtkampf in der cdu
aber eigentlich müsste der appell seien
leute reißt euch zusammen
diese legislatur einigermaßen zu ende es
gibt eine eu ratspräsidentschaft es gibt
eine trank wiederwahl so meine prognose
für den herbst das heißt es kommen
unruhige zeiten von außen auch auf
deutschland zu und wenn ihr euch nicht
irgendwie an der kandare nehmen oder
euch zusammen reißt wird es neuwahlen
geben da bin ich bei herrn schwennicke
ich würde gern mal ein gedanke noch
aufnehmen den sieg gebracht haben mit
der trennung des amtes nachdem hacker
daran offensichtlich auch gescheitert
ist wäre es aus heutiger sicht nicht
besser gewesen
angela merkel hätte diesem druck nicht
nachgegeben und wer zu mindestens noch
bis ende dieses jahres parteichefin
geblieben
sie musste diesen druck nachgeben das
war ja nicht freiwillig es war eine
serie von wahlniederlagen die der
hessen-wahl schon voraus gehen und die
hessen wahl war dann einfach eine abwahl
der cdu zu viel oder einer abwahl auch
der großen koalition in berlin zu viel
und sie wusste und das stimmt ja was für
münster man sagt das macht sie nicht
einfach so sondern nur in allergrößter
not ihm wusste sie muss hier mal einen
sandsack abwerfen
sie hat ja selber immer gesagt das
gehört in eine hand und hat damals wenn
ich mich richtig erinnere auch von einem
wagnis gesprochen was frau kramp
karrenbauer dann eingegangen ist nicht
sie ich finde es übrigens auch noch
einmal bezug auf ihre muntere
anmoderation dass ich so kritisch der
bundeskanzlerin gegenüber stehe
das war nicht immer der fall sondern das
hat 2015 2016 seinen ursprung gehabt und
ich finde diese den den sendungstitel ja
auch ich musste ein bisschen schmunzeln
ehrlich gesagt als ich ihnen als ich ihn
gesehen habe weil konstante merkel hätte
ich schon eine bemerkenswerte
formulierung in meinen augen sind ja in
meinen augen ist hier nicht die
konstante sondern die diskussion der
letzten jahre gewesen sie ist im grunde
jetzt in die situation gekommen ja opfer
auch ihrer der politischen verhältnisse
geworden zu sein die sie selber
hergestellt hat ja die afg groß gemacht
und sie hat ihre eigene partei gespalten
mit der migrationspolitik sisi 2015/2016
ich finde relativ kopflos gemacht hat
und die ergebnisse erreichen sie jetzt
zum ersten mal deswegen reden wir über
die frage wie lange kann sie sich noch
als kanzlerin hatte ich habe hohen
respekt ganz kurz höchst
respekt dass es überhaupt so lange
geschafft habe also ihr kommt gleich auf
dieses thema zurück verspricht gibt es
jemand eine runde der unsere nach langem
nachdenken kreierten sendetitel
unterstützt dass ich eine konstante und
nicht die konstruktion ist wobei
konstante wie gesagt in angst
man kann sicherlich über die frage 2015
streiten da trifft der begriff der
konstanten sicherlich zu arbeiten der
jetzigen situation es sind meine chancen
sagt tatsächlich die konstante sie war
diejenige die erkannt hat wie gefährlich
die situation erfurt nicht nur sozusagen
für das ansehen der cdu und für die
situation in thüringen sondern auch für
die große koalition ist die meines
erachtens nach wenige tage vor dem ende
stand
und deswegen hat sie sehr deutlich
durchgegriffen und letztlich hat sie ja
den nächsten sonntag abgeworfen also ich
halte die geschichte das programm kam
war seit wochen über diesen schritt
nachdenken für sie an den haaren
herbeigezogen das ist ja auch im
gespräch mit sicherheit zwischen den
beiden diese entscheidung am wochenende
getroffen worden und und da bleibt sie
sozusagen in der jetzigen situation der
union die konstante diejenigen die
wirklich auch in der frage des umgangs
mit der afd
eine sehr klare kante gezeigt hat die
sehr klare linie aufgezeigt hat sich da
im übrigen mit söder trifft deswegen
sage ich auch noch die these dass die
frage der kanzlerkandidatur durch die
cdu vorsitz auch noch nicht entschieden
werden wird
herr kretschmann der hund der umstand
dass dieses dilemma in thüringen
beispielsweise ist ja da nicht zum
ersten mal passiert aber jetzt eben so
zugespitzt passiert dass dieses dilemma
sich entscheiden zu müssen zwischen im
einen bösen jetzt ausblick der cdu der
afg und dem anderen bösen ausblick der
cdu nämlich der linken dieses dilemma
das können also fällt mir immer schwer
anzunehmen dass zu bestreiten von jemand
anderem dass das das durch ihre politik
hatte war das dieses dilemma ist die cdu
durch ihre eigene form alle ge
vorsitzende und kanzlerin kürzlich zwei
also wenn sie sich wahrscheinlich
da sich die wähler entwicklung in
thüringen mal angucken dann hatte die
cdu in thüringen die hälfte ihrer wähler
schon verloren bevor frau merkel
überhaupt kanzlerin geworden ist also
ich halte das für eine ganz starke
verkürzung die geschichte so zu erzählen
als ob man an dieser situation frau
merkel alleine schuld ist und sie ist
natürlich im moment die konstante sie
ist er übrigens auch die die sich von
dieser ständigen neuwahl hysterie
am wenigsten tangieren lässt und schon
deshalb ist sie es ihnen ist eine
konstante weil das ist ja so ein
spezifikum dieser diskussion über die
große koalition bei jeder noch relativ
normalen regierungskrise bei jedem
richtungsstreit den alle regierungen der
nachkriegszeit hatten wird bei der
gruppe immer gleich nach neuwahlen
geschrieben und nach ich finde dass ich
finde da fehlt da geht auch oft so ein
bisschen maß und mitte in der diskussion
verloren dass ich nochmal weil es die
frage geht wer ist schuld an dem dilemma
der union zwei punkte noch mal aufrufen
die mit angela merkel eng verbunden ist
da hieß es als sagen die einen die
flüchtlingspolitik vor allen dingen der
herbst 2015 der hätte das land gespalten
so lange ist das noch gar nicht her was
wäre eigentlich die alternative gewesen
wenn sie das nicht so gemacht hätte wie
sie es gemacht hat ich würde es so nicht
fürs gerne so formulieren die
flüchtlingspolitik ist vielleicht der
anlass gewesen er für den durchbruch der
afg es aber nicht die eigentliche
ursache gewesen
die ursachen für das entstehen einer
rechtspopulistischen partei die liegen
viel viel tiefer und ich sind auch im
dezember 2005 zehn jahre schon ziemlich
am boden war genau die war weder am
boden aber sozusagen das potenzial von
von unzufriedenen protestwählern ja das
hatte sich in den zwei jahrzehnten
vorher schon gebildet die fdp die die
afg sozialen dieser zweiten phase ist
ganz stark nichtwähler mobilisierungs
partei das wird häufig auch durch die
wählerwanderung statistiken die da sehr
unzuverlässig sind
das sozusagen unterschätzt also ich gehe
davon aus dass das etwa die hälfte
derjenigen die heute afd wählen
sozusagen aus diesem strukturellen
nichtwähler bereich kommen der sich seit
den neunziger und nuller jahren
aufgebaut hat und das ist sozialer da
liegen viel viel stärker die ursachen
also in repräsentations lücken
entstanden und ich glaube dass diese
flüchtlingskrise dann sozusagen wäre der
anlass der anlass war an dem sich das
dann aufgehängt hat sich ja frau merkel
oder 2017 einer wahl gestellt das war
zwei jahre später sie wurde gewählt sie
hat es nach vielen mühen geschafft eine
regierung auf die beine zu stellen
und deswegen finde ich die konstante ja
ist eine gewählte regierungschefin wir
sehen jetzt gerade in thüringen wie
schwierig das sein kann überhaupt dieses
ab zu erlangen und sie ist nunmal
kanzlerin und die verfassung gibt eine
hohe hürde für neuwahlen eine kanzlerin
kann nicht einfach sagen auch heute
vielleicht ist mir das doch alles zu
viel ich gehe deswegen finde ich kreidet
wenn ihr auch immer an diesen behaarung
willen und sie will nicht weichen ja
kann sie gar nicht in dieser phase und
sie kann auch nicht bei jeder
personaldiskussion sagen stimmt der
müsste jetzt oder die müsste jetzt
eigentlich den vortritt gewährt bekommen
in dieser sendung wird nichts auf die
lange bank geschoben kommt er gleich
auch noch mal drauf wenn das stimmt was
erfährt kann jetzt gesagt hat dass ich
das schon viel früher aufgebaut hat
fragt man sich natürlich wieso konnte
sich angela merkel 15 jahre an der macht
halten im kanzleramt
diese alten zahl von jahren ist nicht
annähernd ein sozialdemokratischer
amtsinhaber gekommen
das ist irgendwie doch nicht erklärbar
horst seehofer der ja ausgerechnet heute
was ich sehr interessant fand unser
innenminister noch mal erwähnte er
erwarte eine flüchtlingskrise erneut im
ausmaße von eventuell 2015
der hat ja immer eine einfache antwort
auf die frage warum frau merkel so lange
an der macht ist er sagt immer jahr
schauen sie auf den männer friedhof
hinter dem kanzleramt da liegen sie alle
die frau merkel in ihrer amtszeit in
anführungszeichen gemeuchelt hat heißt
es ist eine unglaubliche
machtpolitikerin die es schon geschafft
hat sich alle innerparteilichen gegner
oder in der innerhalb der union zu
entledigen danke für das stichwort
politisch mächtigen das wäre kommt jetzt
die überleitung auf die 2 den zweiten
vorwurf an die kanzlerin sie hätte die
sozialdemokratisierung der cdu
vorangetrieben
wenn man sich ansieht wie sich die
kräfteverhältnisse zwischen cdu csu und
spd seit 2005 der ersten großen
koalition unter merkel verschoben haben
dann könnte man sich wie das michael
nicht unbedingt
einmal aufnehmen aber dass die kanzlerin
mit dieser politik die spd geradezu an
die wand gequetscht hat und eigentlich
auch dem sprichwort lügen gestraft hat
dass man lieber das original als die
kopie welt er war das wirklich so unklug
oder warum distanzieren sich so viele
unionspolitiker von einem volks projekt
das ist ja offensichtlich war wenn man
sich die wahlergebnisse ansieht ich will
tue mich schwer mit dem begriff der
sozialdemokratisierung dessen was sie
getan hat würde gerne bei einem veerkamp
anknüpfen weil ich die these noch aus
einem anderen blickwinkel unterstützen
möchte und dann komme ich zu frau merkel
die die spaltung in unserem land in
unserer gesellschaft hat schon viel
früher angesetzt 2015 die tatsache das
ist wieder eine gefühlte und eine reale
spaltung beispielsweise zwischen stadt
und land in diesem jahr in diesem land
gibt die wir schon alle mal überwunden
glaubten das ist dass die spaltung
zwischen sozusagen arm und reich
zwischen oben und unten die
aufstiegsmöglichkeiten abgenommen haben
und die spaltung zugenommen das hat viel
früher angesetzt und jetzt kommt frau
merkel die stadt diese das würde hätte
ich und einer sozialdemokratischen
politik verstanden
deswegen tue ich mit dem begriff rennen
statt diese spaltung sozialen zu
thematisieren und eine politik dagegen
zu entwickeln hat sie versucht
politische unterschiede zuzukleistern
und konflikte kleinzureden und letztlich
für die demokratie dieses landes nicht
sehr förderlich sagen weiße salbe über
die über die wunden gestreut und damit
die spaltung negiert damit politische
unterschiede negiert und dann kommt das
momentum 2016 seinem nach der ersten
begeisterungswelle bridges wellcome wo
sozusagen sich an der migrationsfrage
plötzlich dieses eruptiv alles darstellt
was aber meine sache schon die letzten
10 15 jahren
aber das was ich jetzt sagen dass sie
sich auch auf diese sogenannte
asymmetrische demobilisierung im
wahlkampf das war doch eigentlich ein
geniale wahlkampfstrategie das hat ja
manche spd politiker zu der verwegenen
wahlanalyse
diese gebracht angela merkel sei an der
wahlniederlage der spd schuld was ich
irgendwie auch nicht so richtig
nachvollziehen konnte dass man das offen
zugibt das kommt jetzt darauf an was man
zum obersten ziel erklärt wenn man zum
obersten ziel erklärt an der macht zu
bleiben und alle anderen parteien auch
koalitionspartner so klein wie möglich
zu machen ist das eine sehr gute
strategie
die formation demokratie eigentlich
normal ja es hat halt einen großen
nachteil
kretschmann hat es gerade schon gesagte
demokratie hat da schaden genommen würde
ich sagen weil um es mal in einem
vielleicht etwas flapsigen wild zu sagen
das ist dabei ein rührei entstanden aus
den beiden großen volksparteien und die
leute fühlten sich in diesem frühjahr
nicht mehr zu hause oder fanden sich in
diesem reigen nicht mehr wider und sind
deswegen an die ränder gegangen sowohl
zur afg als auch zu den grünen oder den
linken und das ist glaube ich für diese
parlamentarische demokratie wie wir sie
gewohnt waren dies in der bonner
republik war wie sie in der berliner
republik anfangs war nicht sehr gesund
deswegen kann ich auch verstehen dass
jetzt in manchen umfragen gerade in
denen bei den sympathisanten der spd die
frankfurter rundschau hat so eine
gemacht da kann man unterstellen dass da
er eine spd klientel mit abgestimmten
dass da friedrich merz der
lieblingskandidat der leserschaft der
frankfurter rundschau ist warum weil
natürlich mit so einem cdu vorsitzenden
die trennung zwischen spd und cdu wieder
viel stärker zu tage treten würde dafür
davon würde sich die spd dann auch
wieder ein stück gesundung versprechen
die grünen sagen friedrich merz wäre ein
gottesgeschenk für für sie die frage ist
nur ob es wenn wir dabei bleiben das
gottesgeschenk auch für die union wäre
oder ob nicht dann möglicherweise wenn
frau merkel ab tritt herr merz kommt die
mitte doch nicht mehr bei der union zu
finden ist und wir auf einmal eine grün
rot rote mehrheit im lande haben
vielleicht die grünen dann zwei
machtoptionen haben bei der nächsten
wahl nämlich schwarz und eine linke
mehrheit zu bilden und das wäre für die
union
dann das haus möglicherweise hat ja der
vergangene montag robert habeck dem
kanzleramt ein ziemliches stück näher
gebracht
kann man das so sagen naja ich glaube
zumindest dass annegret kramp
karrenbauer mit ihrem schritt den ich
übereilt zwar richtig aber über alt fand
ihrer partei keinen gefallen getan hat
zumindestens gab es ja bei ihrem
beispiel mit dem männer friedhof gibt es
ja jetzt wohl an ihre inkarnation
nämlich friedrich merz lage auf dem auch
schon mal ist jetzt aber plötzlich
wieder auf der politischen bühne also
aber ob das jetzt passiert oder nicht
ist natürlich ganz entscheidend davon
abhängig wie jetzt die union darauf
reagiert lässt die union sich jetzt so
wie die spd vor 10 15 jahren so ein
richtungsstreit und richtungskampf
aufzwingen an dem sie scheitern wird an
dem sie scheitern wird wenn sie sich
darauf einlässt das ist ja im prinzip
das problem der spd gewesen dass
schulter verursache hat sicherlich 1
varianten des corsa der untersagen
lassen kann wird wohl aber schröder der
spd gemacht hat nämlich eine moderne
partei der politischen mitte zu werden
von der partei nie wirklich angenommen
worden ist immer strittig geblieben ist
und man kann er die geschichte der
sozialdemokratisierung der cdu auch als
modernisierung der cdu wirklich der
regel hat aus der cdu aus einer
konservativen helmut kohl cdu eine
modernisierte pragmatische partei der
mitte gemacht und das bislang so weit
die cdu dieses angebot von frau merkel
angenommen und die große gefahr die ich
jetzt sehe ist dass sie sich jetzt in
einen richtungskampf in mein treiben
lässt der dann genau so endet wie wir
bei der spd diese modernisierung war ja
auch dringend geboten im jahre 2000 also
angela merkel das steuer übernommen
da war die gegen die kohl ära zu ende
selbst wenn man jetzt sagt da gab viele
gab es vieles umstrittene ehe für alle
atomausstieg wehrpflicht mindestlohn
dass sie da eigentlich ist auch
notwendig hatte vor 20 jahren da
wirklich in einer art schocktherapie
modernität in der partei einzuführen das
stimmt ich glaube nur dass das nicht
unmittelbar zu neuen höhen in der
wählergunst geführt hat was sie
beschrieben haben stimmt auch für die
würde einen teil der klientel der cdu
und auch der mitgliedschaft aber wie sie
an den wahlergebnissen sehen ist es kein
keine selbstläufer diese neue von frau
merkel positionierte cdu und ich würde
auch sagen weil das vielleicht jetzt so
ankam dass ich deswegen finde friedrich
merz müsse cdu-vorsitzender das wollte
ich damit gar nicht sagen dass da täten
sich die cdu vielleicht in der hinsicht
keinen gefallen weil es dann wieder so
ein bisschen nach retro richtung helmut
kohl aussieht niemand wie die iren
sparen beispielsweise könnten als als
person so eine art wie soll ich sagen
progressiven konservatismus verkörpern
also die cdu wird es mit sicherheit gut
beraten jetzt nicht in eine kohl cdu
zurück zu fallen aber dass unter wem
auch immer diese merkel cdu ein stück
weit wieder auf ihre kernklientel auf
ihre konservative klientel zu gehen muss
egal wer es macht steht für mich außer
frage wir können gerne in dieser
konstellation ich bin nicht der
moderator dann zudem gegeben uns haben
eine runde waren alles egal wer es wird
ein jeder auch ein herr laschet der
wahrscheinlich eher linksliberal ist
unter den in frage gekommen ist auch er
wird dieser konservativen klientel einen
größeren raum geben müssen als ihm frau
merkel herrn gegeben hat dienstag schon
gehabt und will ich verspreche ihnen wir
machen es auch weiter bleiben da am ball
da würde ich ihm widersprechen es war
keine modernisierung der cdu es war eine
mainstream visierung die cdu hat sich
unter merkel sozusagen den zeitgeist
angepasst und jetzt hat sie das problem
dass weil die spaltungen dieser
gesellschaft zu tage treten und weil sie
mitten durch das klientel der union auch
laufen plötzlich mit dem mainstream
nichts mehr anfangen kann sondern sich
entscheiden muss und wertorientiert
führen mussten meine die frage erfurt zu
entscheiden war doch eine frage gibt es
noch ein funktionierendes wertegerüst in
der union unter nicht und offensichtlich
gibt es auf der mittleren
funktionärsebene in teilen der union
kein funktionierendes wertegerüst mehr
so das ist das ist das ergebnis
sozusagen nicht von modernisierung
sondern von zeitgeist orient
sie ihren können ja und und und darauf
muss jetzt eine antwort in der tat in
der union auch würde ganz gerne ganz
kurz einen ganz kurzen ausflug machen
indigo ist jetzt wieder bei der cdu
wären da auch gleich zurück dass diese
augenblickliche zustand der der union
erleichtert es eigentlich der spd jetzt
in der groko neue forderungen
durchzubringen das neue duo s cabo also
dass gästen und walter borjans haben wir
schon angekündigt sie wollten auch über
den koalitionsvertrag hinaus noch
einiges umsetzen erleichtert dass dieses
ansinnen oder erschwert ist das
umgekehrt weil die union gerade die cdu
jetzt erstmal die flanken schließt und
sagt ihr haben wir moment viele probleme
da lassen wir uns jetzt auf keine
abenteuer in der coco mehr ein
meine einschätzung ist dass das
erschwert weil die union und die
spaltung der union ja nicht nur in
dieser frage vorhanden ist nehmen sie
die absurde diskussion die wir um das
thema ausbau von windenergie in
deutschland haben wo sozusagen abstruse
theorien inzwischen in der union in
teilen der union ein widerhall finden
und die koalition im stillstand
angelangt ist da sehen sie dass
sozusagen die die fehlende klarheit in
der union sich an verschiedenen themen
auswirken wird und dass das die frage
nach es gar nicht weil es die spd
fordert sondern überhaupt die frage
handlungsfähigkeit für neue
herausforderungen
ob die noch gegeben ist oder ob es ein
sklavisches abarbeiten des
koalitionsvertrages wird da bin ich in
der tat fast bei herrn ständige zu
glauben das wird schwierig werden neue
impulse in diese koalition reinzutragen
mit denen die groko druck von dieser
seite also das heißt dass man sich in
zwei über das programm der coco keine
gefahr mehr
interessant war dass die grundrente ja
eigentlich diese woche im kabinett
behandelt werden sollte es wurde dann
verschoben
aufgrund der ereignisse rund um
thüringen und auch weil man sich
irgendwie bei der finanzierung doch noch
nicht so ganz klar ist sprich ich glaube
es gibt noch brocken die diese kroko
inhaltlich anzugehen hat grundrente die
ganze klimakiste die jetzt auf dem weg
ist und die noch überhaupt nicht durch
diskutiert ist in den ministerien und
jedes manöver das wieder dazu führt dass
es eine selbstbeschäftigung ist wie ich
vorhin schon sagte die spd hat es hinter
sich
im wird dazu führen dass es
verzögerungen gibt und dass man sich
auch gar nicht richtig darauf
konzentrieren kann ich frage mich auch
immer wie frau kramp karrenbauer bei all
diesen dingen eigentlich noch
verteidigungsministerin ist die münchner
sicherheitskonferenz steht vor der tür
und irgendwie hat man das gefühl das
feld dann so etwas hinten und zumindest
einen wichtigen termin mit markus söder
und will über die nachfolge an der
zusatzbezeichnung zu sprechen wenn sie
denn die schlussbilanz vorliegen können
über die groko dass man dann sagt also
selbst wenn es so schön gesagt
handlungsfähig sind sie temperamentvoll
nicht wenn man sagt zumindest haben sie
formaljuristisch den koalitionsvertrag
abgearbeitet also sie meinen ob wir dann
noch mal fleißkärtchen verteilen so
bestanden also ich glaube schon dass ein
bisschen das problem ist dass die großen
themen eigentlich mehr oder weniger
abgearbeitet sind das so richtig ein
marazzi für die nächsten anderthalb
jahre nicht mehr besteht man darf aber
nicht vergessen das zweite halbjahr wird
sehr stark geprägt sein durch die
gestaltung der präsidentschaft in
europäischen union da ist das ganze
kabinett die ganze bundesregierung
gefragt und
und eingebunden und wenn man sich dann
mal den wahlkalender anschaut 21 essen
war ja das geht im märz los mit baden
württemberg rheinland pfalz im juni geht
es weiter mit sachsen anhalt und
planmäßig im herbst dann die die
bundestagswahl
also von daher sehe ich da eigentlich
wenig raum jetzt noch für eine große
regierungskrise ich kann auch eigentlich
jetzt nicht erkennen welche partei da
wirklich interesse daran haben sollte
zumal die frage die frau münstermann
schon schon gestellt hat ist wie könnte
das denn überhaupt gehen das grundgesetz
hat die hürde für neuwahlen extrem hoch
gesetzt ja und das ist ja gar nicht so
einfach man also jetzt eine
vertrauensfrage ist ja nicht das
instrument irgendwie der der
lebensplanung einer bundeskanzlerin oder
irgendwie ein instrument der
parteitaktik zur maximierung von von
wahlchancen sondern da geht es um
handlungsfähigkeit sozusagen der einzige
grund über eine vertrauensfrage
neuwahlen herzustellen der
verfassungsgemäß wäre wäre wenn man
sagen muss wir haben eine nicht mehr
handlungsfähige regierung die regierung
hat im parlament keine mehrheit mehr
davon sind wir meilenweit entfernt der
junge stabil hat eine mehrheit hat auch
noch ein rest programm abzuarbeiten
ich sehe überhaupt nicht wo da eine
begründung her kommen sollte neu war ein
zufallstreffer es auch gar nicht warum
man automatisch immer ausschließlich und
nur bei neuwahlen landen soll in dieser
frage denn ich habe es ja vorhin gesagt
es könnte ja sein dass einer der
kandidaten oder auch alle eine bedingung
stellen die sich eben lang dieses satzes
dieses satzes am kanzleramt und
parteivorsitz gehört und dass die spd
das vor allem herr klingen weil aber
auch anreise gerne reise geht er jetzt
gesagt haben wir haben diese koalition
mit frau merkel gemacht und machen die
sonst mit niemandem
also da würde ich mal sagen ist das
allerletzte wort im ernstfall dann auch
noch nicht gesprochen
wir erinnern uns warum sollten sie der
welt einem kandidaten der cdu diesen
vorsprung gewähr
aber vielleicht ja vielleicht von
ostermann mit einer neuwahl mit einer
vorzeitigen neuwahl noch schlechter
dastehen als zum beispiel mit einem
kanzler laschet aber wenn ich monatelang
ins boot holen
ja aber nur ganz kurz nur ganz kurz die
parteispitze die jetzt am ruder ist hat
den wahlkampf den innerparteilichen
wahlkampf gewonnen mit dem mehr oder
minder klar ausgesprochene versprechen
bei nächstbester gelegenheit diese
koalition zu verlassen dabei von davon
merken sie gar nichts mehr so dass ich
mir einfach erlauben zu sagen glauben
wir bitte nicht dass das das allerletzte
wort ist was die spd da jetzt ein
zweites mal nicht das macht was sie
angekündigt hat ich würde mich diesem
thema gerne von der anderen seite noch
mal nähern
wir konnten bleiben jetzt bei diesem
thema bis zum ende der sendung
verspreche ich ihnen krieg die kanzlerin
anders gesagt haben dass der neue
parteivorsitzende aber nicht mehr mit
ihr als kanzlerin blickt könnte es sein
dass die kanzlerin beim zweiten versuch
nach ak doch noch den drahtseilakt
hinkriegt im amt zu bleiben und
gleichzeitig einen nachfolger aufgebaut
aufzubauen der dann von der cdu als
parteivorsitzender gewählt ist das so
unwahrscheinlich oder muss das sofort in
einer gnadenlosen rivalität enden
ich glaube es kommt sehr stark darauf an
tatsächlich wieder das wird also bei
märz wird man das wahrscheinlich eher
wenig einfach nur geil friedrich merz
gibt es einen gibt es ein ernstes
problem für die kanzlerin war natürlich
völlig märz auch so klar
ein wiederaufstieg aus dem eben schon
zitierten friedhof inszeniert hat und
auch gegen angela merkel inszeniert hat
dass das schwierig werden wird sich sich
tatsächlich zu arrangieren
in anderen konstellationen
ich glaube ich würde es schon anders
sein zumal ich also ich halte die
favoriten für dieses für das
kanzlerkandidaten am sind meine sachen
sagt zwei ministerpräsidenten jeweils
eine sehr großen bundeslandes
die haben keine not die frage des
parteivorsitzes oder eine sowieso nicht
weil der csu vorsitzender ist der andere
weil er in nordrhein westfalen regiert
starken landesverband hat wenn ja noch
bundesvorsitzende hat er ist cdu ist
stellt sich für den auch nicht zwingend
die frage ob er die in die gleiche
situation kommt wie annette kramp
karrenbauer weil eine ganz andere
machtbasis ist eine ganz andere
einstellung hat und weil er dieses amt
nur erlangen wird anders als annette
kramp karrenbauer nicht durch einen
wettbewerb zwischen drei kontrahenten
sondern meine sachen so nach wird es
werden wir den nächsten tagen wenigen
wochen einen großen deal im hintergrund
erleben wo alle mehr oder weniger
vielleicht lässt sich für die schmerzen
nicht einbinden aber alle anderen namen
die hier gefallen sind inklusive der
kanzlerin an diesem großen paket mit
geschnürt haben die kanzlerin wird dafür
auch bereit sein den wirtschaftsminister
zu opfern beispielsweise und ähnlich ist
also das sind glaube ich arrangements an
der stelle funktioniert ja die union
immer noch und hat sie immer
funktioniert da sie kriegt zwar
bestimmte grundsatzkonflikt nicht
geklärt aber wie man am ende
machtarithmetik so zusammensetzt dass
man macht nicht hergeben muss das
scheint mir immer noch in der unseres
wirklich neues zu sagen da gibt es einen
nachfolger der von der kanzlerin
gefördert wird und sich dafür noch etwas
in geduld üben
naja ich glaube das problem liegt darin
dass man jetzt ganz schnell einen
vorsitzenden und gleichzeitig irgendwie
ein kanzler kandidaten benennen muss
wenn wir jetzt mal überlegen es gibt
einen parteivorsitzenden armin laschet
ministerpräsident cdu chef und die
partei sagt wir schauen jetzt mal wen
wir als kanzlerkandidaten aufstellen und
vielleicht kommt es so dass wirklich
markus söder als csu-mann die einzige
waffe gegen die afg ist in einem jahr
und die einzige waffe die sozusagen uns
gegen
für und mit den grünen spricht die afg
halten wir uns vom leib aber mit den
grünen könnten wir zusammengehen
vielleicht dass er der richtige mann
also ich denke wenn die cdu und die
union insgesamt klug beraten ist klären
sie jetzt zwar schnell die frage des cdu
vorsitzes die kanzlerkandidatur um die
cdu hat eine vorsitzende und die
vorsitzende hat ja auch angeboten ihre
amtszeit sozusagen zu ende zu bringen
und den prozess weiter zu
ich glaube das nicht
ihre serie gut beraten wenn sie die
einen zeitplan einhält ja und sie hat
eine grundsatzprogramm diskussion sie
hat eine organisatorische neuaufstellung
sie wird sozusagen an dem wahltermin im
herbst nächsten jahres wenig ändern
können und ich würde es wirklich für
leichtfertig halten sozusagen jetzt
wieder jemanden ins rennen zu schicken
der dann irgendwie für anderthalb jahre
was ist er dann kandidaten kandidat ist
oder was auch immer ich glaube wenn da
jetzt mal so ein bisschen ruhe einkehrt
in die diskussion es gab ja auch schon
erste gewichtige stimmen beispielsweise
vom bundestagspräsidenten schäuble dass
die union wirklich gut beraten wäre an
diesem zeitplan erst mal nichts
ich will das gar nicht langweilig den
zeitplan der lhrd an sechs monate
vorsitz suche sind tödlich darf ich da
mal eine zeit lang skizzieren es wir
haben immer mit ein machtvakuum da ist
eine parteivorsitzende auf abruf selbst
gesagt hat absehbare zeit eine kanzlerin
deren verbleib im amt auch beschränkt
ist es ja selbst gesagt was spricht
dagegen bis zum sommer sich einen
parteivorsitzenden zu suchen und erst im
spätherbst diesen kanzlerkandidaten zu
benennen da muss ja noch marco soda
miteinbezogen werden selbst wenn er bei
seiner meinung bleibt er ist es nicht
es ist ja schlecht wenn das beide
zusammen beschlossen wird dann hätte er
so wieder ja faktisch auch eine
mitsprache beim parteivorsitzenden gar
nichts spricht dagegen so genau dass man
erst später den kanzlerkandidaten damit
zum ende des jahres benennt und dann
hätte sie da noch ein mitspracherecht
beim kanzlerkandidaten könnte vielleicht
noch etwas rausholen für zukünftige
ressort verteilungen also genau das
zusammensein nein also genauso herum
wird ein schuh draus und nicht so um
frau kramp karrenbauer im ersten effekt
nenne ich jetzt mal es war das da werde
ich will ich auch mildernde umstände
wirklich geltend machen da das ist dann
in so einem moment vielleicht noch nicht
bis zu ende durchgedacht aber natürlich
muss erst der cdu-vorsitzende oder die
cdu-vorsitzende gefunden werden und dann
der kanzlerkandidat oder die
kanzlerkandidatin war das wiederum mit
der schwesterpartei csu und da hat
markus söder
völlig zu recht gleich gesagt hallo da
sind auch noch hier und da bin übrigens
auch noch ich heißt nicht dass ich das
beanspruche dieses amt also
kanzlerkandidatur beanspruche aber da
reden wir ein wörtchen mit also ist es
ganz logisch dass erst und zwar früher
als im dezember 2020 ein cdu
parteivorsitzender gefunden und
mindestens mal nominiert ist vielleicht
auch kommissarisch eingesetzt ich kenne
es die statuten nicht gut genug der cdu
um das sagen zu können ob dies genau so
machen können wie die spd
nachdem andrea nahles ging waren drei
kommissarisch eingesetzt ich glaube von
parteivorstand und gut war's das kann
man aber die person muss feststehen
bevor der kanzlerkandidat das würde das
alles am jahresende erst in trockenen
tüchern ist nach dieser nach diesen
zeitlichen ablauf dann braucht man ja
eigentlich nicht unbedingt
bundestagswahl vorzuziehen dann kann man
ja eigentlich die legislaturperiode so
richtig auslaufen das war sie würden
auch dann wenn sie dann sozusagen im
neuen jahr anfangen ein neuer prozess
einzuleiten gewinnen sie nur wenige
monate sind im frühsommer oder eben
regulär im september und dann macht es
auch sinn eines eines inthronisierten
und kanzlerkandidaten nicht mehr viel
unterschied ob er das aus dem amt heraus
führt diesen wahlkampf oder oder aus dem
aus dem vorsitz amt insofern glaube ich
deswegen auch dass das szenario wäre
wäre an der stelle für die kanzlerin
stabilisieren das ist aber an anderer
stelle natürlich insbesondere dann wenn
man wenn man sehr lange auch den
konflikt in der union gibt und die frage
eben nicht klar erklärt und dann ist es
ein konjunkturprogramm für robert habeck
als bundeskanzler und im übrigen wenn
dabei auch noch dann die werte union
ihre entsprechende rolle versucht
einzunehmen und und sozusagen auch
grundsatzfragen immer wieder in frage
gestellt ist es dann auch ein
konjunkturprogramm dafür dass robert
habeck eine grün rot rote koalition
anführt man muss ja auch sagen also mal
gesetzt den fall es gebe ein
cdu-vorsitzenden dem mehr kraft hat als
frau kramp karrenbauer ich erinnere mich
an eine zeit europawahlkampf da wurde
merkel immer vorgeworfen sie würde
überhaupt nicht mehr für die partei
auftreten
sie würde ja kramp karrenbauer die bühne
überlassen sie würde sich so
zurückhaltend
sodann kam jetzt diese geschichte mit
der afg hatakka das adenauer haus
einfach versagt den thüringischen
landeschef der cdu mike mohring
einzubremsen oder in eine ihm eine
richtung vorzugeben und bei dem thema
afd war es klar muss sich merkel äußern
wird sich merkel äußern sie ist
kanzlerin von deutschland da muss man
was sagen zu diesen vorgängen mit der
afg und außerdem ist es ihr herzensthema
gegen antisemitismus und
fremdenfeindlichkeit vorzugehen das ist
mit ihr verbunden es war klar dass sie
sich äußert jetzt äußert sie sich sehr
deutlich und dann heißt es jetzt hat die
kanzlerin aber der parteivorsitzenden
sozusagen das wasser abgegraben
sprich ein starker cdu-chef so wird es
nun mal sein jetzt wäre vielleicht
durchaus in der lage auch mit einer
kanzlerin noch anderthalb jahre weiter
zu gestern nicht käme kann man sich
wirklich einen wechsel im kanzleramt
vorstellen vorzeitig vor dem herbst 2021
ohne neuwahlen also ohne vorgezogene
neuwahl ist sagen an bord des laufenden
schiffes in der jetzigen
legislaturperiode auch mit diesen mehr
als felder ich habe ja meine
offensichtlich am tisch um eine
minderheitsmeinung gar schon kundgetan
dass ich das sehr wohl und dass das nein
der spd zu jemand anderem da zwar im
moment ein kategorisches ist aber kein
endgültiges seien nur unter dieser
voraussetzung geht das denn sonst würde
man ja gefahr laufen dass sich der
erfurter landtag wiederholt
gefragt wie es geht und da habe ich
gesagt so wird das heißt wenn die spd
dabei reicht dabei bleibt zu sagen wir
machen da nicht mit was klingbeil
gestern gesagt hat dann gibt es diese
neuwahlen denn da gibt es noch lange
keine neuwahlen sondern die schon
erwähnten hohen hürden können dann dazu
führen dass es plötzlich eine kanzlerin
merkel gibt die von der eigenen partei
nicht mehr gewollt wird aber es gibt
niemanden in der lage ist einen neuen
kanzler zu installieren und es gibt ist
damit noch nicht gesagt dass es zu
neuwahlen kommen nicht immer
verständlich dass frauen zu schlagen war
aber zum thema neuwahlen und verkehr aus
frage meine wenn uns thüring etwas
gelehrt hat ist ist es doch die
spielregeln der demokratie ernst zu
nehmen und dazu gehört auch so ein
instrument wie die vertrauensfrage und
neuwahlen
sozusagen nicht dafür zu missbrauchen
irgendwelche wahltaktischen oder wan
optimierungs kalküle zu erfüllen der
deutsche bundestag ist für vier jahre
gewählt
die bundeskanzlerin hat sich gegenüber
den wählerinnen und wählern festgelegt
dass sie für die komplette
legislaturperiode zur verfügung stehen
die regierungsmehrheit ist stabil
welchen grund sollte es denn dann geben
über eine vertrauensfrage neuwahlen
herzustellen
das würde ja auch bedeuten denn die
negativ aus ginge und der bundestag sich
nicht für neuwahlen entscheidet müsste
er ja jemand anders zum bundeskanzler
wählen ohne die spd könnte sich das
drama von erfurt wiederholen denn dann
könnten cdu fdp und ob sie wollen oder
nicht in einer geheimen abstimmung ja
auch die afg einen neuen kanzler wählen
was die cdu wohlweislich verhindern wird
also insofern bietet chef christian
lindner noch mal angesehen gefolgt auf
solche szenarien wird sich durch die
union nicht einlassen ja das ist denn
die dna der union die dna der union ist
dass sie eine staatstragende
regierungspartei ist und die wird sich
doch nicht weil sie sich einem
kandidaten in den arm schmeißt jetzt
diese ganzen prinzipien der letzten
jahrzehnte über den haufen werfen und
der regierungskrise veranstalten nur um
irgendwie frühzeitig einen
kanzlerkandidaten zu installieren ich
kann mir das nicht vorstellen
ich bedanke mich für das gespräch wir
sind schon am ende dieser sendung und
wenn das genau beobachten was aus der
ganzen sache wird wie spannend das noch
werden kann
dann gehe ich liebe zuschauer bleiben
sie bei phoenix
[Musik]